[Music]
we're used to seeing selling sunset star
christelle stauss inside multi-million
dollar estates but her latest gig has a
big change of scenery check out crochetl
inside a convenience store making out
with g-flip
escape
rochelle stars as the australian
musician's leading lady in their music
video for get me out of here the steamy
project comes nearly a week after
krashel confirmed they're a real life
couple at the selling sunset reunion
special i recently have been spending a
lot of time with someone that's very
important to me their name is he flip
they're non-binary so they go by they
them and they are an extremely talented
musician and it started because you know
i was just going to be in their video
and it's about this chaotic love story
and now the visual is out and the
chemistry between the two is undeniable
they make out a lot like a lot a lot all
over a kwik-e-mart and there's also
these shots crashell sitting on g's lap
yeah like we said the pda is heavy
[Music]
the reality star shared the video on her
instagram and got cheeky in the caption
quote sorry everyone i was confused and
thought this was how babies were made
back to the drawing board g flip
responded in the comments you're
absolutely amazing at the reunion quest
said she didn't think fans would be
ready for the hot and heavy video she
was also hesitant about sharing details
about her new relationship i think i was
probably as surprised as anyone um just
because nothing's really changed for me
i'm still very attracted to masculine
energy and a good human okay i hear
people talk about these things and
they're like i knew from a young age and
that's not me i know being in this
position
we get judged constantly
but at the end of the day i
i'm i'm so happy and so if if that
angers someone then that's not really my
problem no judgment and just days after
krishel found herself defending her
romance and i know that some of you
won't understand this or agree with this
but for me
it is about the person it is about their
heart as for why well some fans called
her out for ending things with her last
bow jason oppenheim after realizing they
have different dreams when it comes to
starting a family but krishell insists
her goals have not changed since g-flip
entered the picture in this current
situation with g
it's one of those things that yes i i i
wish you know we
are in the same stage of our life and we
wanted the same things but that doesn't
diminish
you know
how the deep connection that we have
made
and the way that they have
opened my eyes to
you know what that future could look
like as for how things are going between
jason and gracel now that she's in a new
relationship as much as
i wish
what i wanted in my last relationship
aligned you know the same things it
didn't
and that's okay that doesn't diminish
how much love
um you know we have for each other jason
and i and how much we want each other to
genuinely be happy and it's true jason
has nothing but love for his ex and her
relationship with g flip not only did
jason leave this supportive comment on
christelle's instagram video but he also
praised the couple during the reunion
they seems like a badass yeah one uh and
two
the smile that's been on your face the
last couple minutes makes me very happy
so um i'm proud of you
[Music]
you